we're asked to simplify the expression
by removing all factors that are perfect
squares from inside the radicals and
combining the terms so let's see if we
can do it and and pause the video and
give a go at it before we do it together
all right so let's see how we can
rewrite these radicals so 4 times the
square root of 20 well that's the same
thing as 4 times the square root of 4
times the square root of 5 because 20 is
the same thing as 4 times 5 and 45
that's the same thing as 9 times 5 and
the reason why I'm thinking about the 4
and I'm thinking about the 9 is because
those are perfect squares so I could
write this as 4 times the square root of
4 times the square root of 5 and then I
could say this part right over here is
minus 3 times the square root of 9 times
the square root of 5 square root of 45
is the same thing as the square root of
9 times 5 which is the same thing as
square root of 9 times the square root
of 5 and then all of that is going to be
over all of that is over the square root
of 35 now are there any are there any
perfect squares in 35 35 is 7 times 5 no
neither of those are perfect squares so
I could just leave that as square root
of 35 and let's see square root of 4
well that's going to be 2 this is the
principal roots or thing about the
positive square root square root of 9 is
3 and so this part right over here is
going to be 4 times 2 times the square
root of 5 so it's going to be 8 square
roots of 5 and then this part over here
is going to be minus 3 times 3 times the
square root of 5 so minus 9 square roots
of 5 and all of that is going to be over
the square root of 35 square root of 35
and so let's see if I have 8 of
something and I subtract 9 of that
something I'm going to have negative 1
of that something so I could say
negative 1 times the square root of 5 or
I could just say negative square root of
5 negative square root of 5 over the
square root of 35 I actually think I
could simplify this even more
because this is the same thing this is
equal to the negative of the square root
of 5 over 35 both the numerator and
denominator divisible by 5 so we could
divide them both by 5 and we would get
the square root of divide the numerator
by 5 you get 1 divide the denominator by
5 you get 7 so we can view this as a
square root of 1/7 square root of 1/7
and we are all done let's do another one
of these these are strangely strangely
fun and once again pause it and see if
you can work it out on your own perform
the indicated operations all right
so let's first multiply so this
essentially is doing the distributive
property twice and actually let me just
do it that way so let's distribute the
square root of 5 plus the square root of
6
let's first multiply it times the square
root of 5 so square root of 5 times
square root of 5 is going to be 5 square
root of 5 times the square root of 6 is
the square root of 30 so 5 plus the
square root of 30 and then when I take
this when I take this expression and I
multiply it times the second term times
the negative square root of 6 well
negative square root of 6 times the
square root of 5 is going to be the
negative of the square root of 30 and
then the negative of the square root of
6 times the square root of 6 is going to
be we're going to subtract 6 square root
of 6 times square root of 6 is 6 then we
have the negative out there and so just
like that we are left with well as C
square root of 30 minus square root of
30
well those cancel out that's 0 and we're
left with 5 minus 6 which is going to be
equal to which is going to be equal to
negative 1 and we are we're we're all
done now another way that you could have
viewed this as you could have seen a
pattern here you could have said well
this is the same thing as a plus B times
a minus B where a is square root of 5
and B is square root of 6 and we know
that this will result in the difference
of squares this will be a squared minus
B squared and so for this particular
case it would be square root of 5
squared minus square root of 6 squared
which of course is equal to 5 minus 6
which is equal to negative 1 either way
hopefully you found that vaguely
entertaining